bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour ce
premier débat thématique des élections
régionales tous les samedis jusqu'au
premier tour france 3 organise le débat
autour des principales compétences du
conseil régional au programme
aujourd'hui la culture le patrimoine le
tourisme et bien sûr l'identité de notre
nouvelle région bourgogne franche comté
une émission diffusée bien sûr sur
l'ensemble de cette nouvelle région et
animée avec vous catherine bonjour
bonjour liant bonjour à tous
eh bien nous allons commencer par
présenter nos six invités présents sur
ce plateau lors tout d'abord jérôme
durain il est sénateur de saône-et-loire
conseiller régional sortant et les
candidats pour la liste socialiste de
marie-guite dufay
face à lui se trouve jean philippe
lefebvre adjoint à la culture à dole
dans le jura
candidat pour la liste elle est rude et
y de françois sauvadet
brigitte monnet c'est la seule femme sur
ce plateau qui est conseil régional de
franche-comté maire de vincelles dans le
jura elle est candidate pour la liste
europe écologie les verts de cécile
prud'hommes jacques richard petit
merdeux tressens d'antan doux représente
ici la liste de sophie montel du front
national jérôme petit dans mr de faim
les mutti en côte-d'or et de là pour la
liste de nathalie vermorel
l'alternative à gauche et puis pour
finir charles henry gallois tête de
liste régionale de l'upm l'union
populaire républicaine alors on va
commencer tout de suite à entrer dans le
vif du débat dans le vif du sujet avec
une question concernant l'identité c'est
ça qui va déterminer la suite de
différents débats au 1er janvier 2016
date de la fusion entre la bourgogne et
la franche-comté vous sentirez vous
madame messieurs bourguignon franc
comtois ou membres de cette nouvelle
grande région ont commencé avec un
conseiller régional sortant vous
monsieur du rhin moi je crois qu on se
sentira tout ce bourguignon franc
comtois faut rappeler que ce
rapprochement il a été d'abord
volontariste une loi est venu qui a créé
13 nouvelles grandes régions mais
marie-guite dufay françois patriat avait
eu déjà pris l'initiative de rapprocher
ces deux grandes régions que sont la
bourgogne et la franche comté
parce qu'il a des complémentarités
évidentes il ya un destin commun
un destin qui fait sur une histoire
industrielle une histoire agricole ce
sont deux grands territoires industriels
agricoles un patrimoine remarquable
naturels historiques
une convention une culture des lettres à
neutre je vous fais le plan une culture
du bien vivre et des productions de
qualité donc avait évidemment un destin
commun on sera tous bourguignon franc
comtois brigitte monnet vous êtes
l'autre conseillère régionale sortante
sur ce plateau vous qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous entendu jurassienne 1er
janvier vous êtes bourguignonne franc
comtoise moi je suis un habitant d'une
habitante de ce monde j'ai envie de dire
et il se trouve que je suis né en
saône-et-loire et j'ai vu aujourd'hui en
france comptait donc habitants du monde
ça veut dire que l'entité régionale ne
vous concerne pas
elle me concerne mais on est tous un
habitant de cette planète et on a tous
les mêmes préoccupations de préservation
de de cette planète de sa culture
et concernant la bourgogne france-comté
nous avons énormément de choses en
commun qui ont été dites par
l'interlocuteur précédent qui sont
l'authenticité de nos paysages
là la culture industrielle de notre de
nos territoires la france comté est la
première région industrielle de france
c'est aussi la ruralité
il ne faut pas oublier que la bourgogne
franche comté sera à la région qui a le
moins d'habitants qui habite la ville et
ça c'est un élément important pour les
politiques à venir aussi bien
culturelles que touristique
jean philippe lefebvre vous
et élus à dole on l'a dit dans la
présentation à équidistance quasiment où
le sang c'est un des centres président
de cette grande région et vous
appartenait à une famille politique qui
était alors à certains moments moins
favorable à la fusion puis finalement
globalement aujourd'hui oui vous serez
bourguignon franc comtois les deux ça
vous prendra pas le pousser moi je pense
que si la grande région c'est une entité
c'est pas une identité donc on a créé
une nouvelle entité c'est une un mode de
gestion de territoire mais ça ne
remplace pas les territoires j'allais
presque dire les plus anciens d'entre
nous se souviennent de vous savez cette
interpellation du général de gaulle qui
disait dans de goethe chateaubriand sont
respectivement est éminemment italiens
allemands et français et il n'aurait pas
beaucoup servi l'europe s'il avait parlé
en quelques espéranto volapük intégrer
ce que je veux dire par là
ce que je veux dire quand ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que courbet restera
toujours franc comtois parce que ces
paysages sont ceux de la comté et
vincenot restera toujours un écrivain
bourguignon parce que la saveur de son
texte est marqué par la saveur de la
bourgogne est donc pour nous pour les
républicains et les centristes
des collègues de l'ue dei notre notre
projet c'est de respecter les deux
identités celle de la bourgogne et de la
franche comté tout en les administrant
par une entité commune jacques richard
dati front national a été sévère avec ce
projet de fusion
vous vous si vous êtes élu quand vous
siégerait dans la nouvelle assemblée
peut bien évidemment forcément je vais
siéger dans une assemblée de la
bourgogne et de la franche comté
l'entité est clairement défini les
territoires sont définis voilà je
voudrais revenir à skis après ce que
vous vous sentirez comme devant défendre
les intérêts de votre région initiale ou
votre vision politique ce sera celle des
intérêts de ce nouvel ensemble parce que
c'est ça finalement notre question sur
les dents des videmment elle les
fondamentaux de chacun que ce soit que
ce soit l'identité de la franche comté
et l'identité de la bourgogne
on les a mariés on les a mariés je
voudrais bien voir les termes du contrat
enfin vous vous les connaissez comme moi
vous voulez que vous voyez comme moi
c'est un mariage quasiment forcé dans la
précipitation sait pas trop ce qui a
présidé à sale et les populations parce
que je pense que c'est là dessus qu'il
faut revenir les populations sont
totalement déboussolée quand vous voyez
des gens enfin moi j'ai le plaisir de
faire la campagne aux côtés de sophie
montel vous allez vous allez à
l'encontre des populations qu'elle soit
franc comtoise ou bourguignonne elles
sont totalement désemparé vous voyez les
bourguignons compper du côté industriel
et surpuissant du nord franche-comté
chez nous vous avez des légendes un de
la franche comté qui ont peur de la
toute-puissance bourguignonne
et dire que la bourgogne semble moins
inquiètes des conséquences que la
franche comté mais moi c'est un peu ce
que je pensais et au vu du terrain j'ai
vu certaines inquiétudes
particulièrement plein ouest du côté de
nevers ou là ces gens là se sentent
totalement désemparés et le front
national défendra ses titres c'est
irritant oublier monsieur gallois vous
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à l'ibère
l'union populaire républicaine vous
sentirez bourguignon franc comtois je me
permets juste de présenter très
rapidement lui perd en quelques mots
parce que les téléspectateurs ne
connaissent pas forcément
l'upm est un parti assez récent sur la
scène politique qui rassemble déjà plus
de 9000 adhérents ce qui commence à
faire pas mal et c'est un style
adhérents pour la france exactement
et c'est un parti qui se veut au-delà du
clivage gauche droite et contrairement à
d'autres ce n'est pas seulement un
slogan puisque le ministère l'intérieur
lui-même à toutes les dernières
élections nous a classé en listes
diverses c'est à dire ni divers gauche
mais divers droite si on reprend toutes
les polémiques sur les classements du
ministère de l'intérieur je sais pas si
c'est le meilleur
c'est lui au 1er janvier vous vous
sentez bourguignon franc comtois mais
moi je pense en tout cas que c'est un
débat qui est beaucoup plus vaste que
cela est là on part sur des termes très
technique de gestionnaires finalement
qui pourrait être fait par des
gestionnaires qui sont pas forcément des
politiques mais l'important c'est que là
on est sur les élections régionales et
c'est de la politique faudrait expliquer
aux citoyens qui n'ont jamais demandé
les bourguignons et franc comtois n'ont
jamais demandé à fusionner de même que
toutes les sept lois de réforme des
collectivités territoriales cela n'a
jamais été une demande des citoyens
d'ailleurs vous faut quand même se
rappeler qu'à la base il y avait
l'obligation de faire un référendum sur
les fusions des collectivités
territoriales c'est l'amendement gaymard
qui a été votée à la fois par le ps et
les républicains qui a enlevé cette
obligation de référendum ont donc encore
une fois on fait une fusion sans
demander l'avis du peuple et le gros
problème qui a derrière c'est qu'il faut
encore une fois c'est un problème
beaucoup plus vaste
ça peut vous paraître excessif mais ce
qui se passe c'est le démantèlement
programmé de la france c'est toute la
politique d or aux régions qui est menée
et l'idée à terme celle afin d'aider les
communes
c'est la fin des départements et c'est
la fusion de grandes régions qu'ils
négocieraient directement avec bruxelles
et l'état français disparaît
complètement élus père va être le seul
parti à dénoncer ça et c'est ce qui
paraît fondamental on peut partir sur
problème technique d'identité est-ce
qu'on se sent plus ou moins bourguignon
plus ou moins front comtois s'est très
bien ces identités
mais à terme ce qu'il fera en ligne de
mire c'est la disparition programmée de
la france personne n'aurait pu dire par
les banques il ya dix quinze ans que la
catalogne sera au bord de la sécession
avec l'espagne ou que l'ecosse serait au
bord de la sécession avec le royaume uni
et ce qui se joue à l'inter milan mais
pour l'instant on est en bourgogne
franche comté
oui d'accord merci jérôme président je
crois que l'entité
des idées l'identité par contre pour
nous c'est une identité une identité
pardon avant tout républicaine
nous ne souhaitons pas que à travers
cette notion d'identité soient mis en
avant la confrontation des territoires
entre bourgogne centre franche comté ou
des territoires plus locaux nous
souhaitons que cette bourgogne franche
comté puissent s'inscrire dans un
travail on va dire coopératif donc je ne
rentrais pas dans cette polémique
identitaire on convient de parler
d'identité
ça va nous amener forcément à ce qu'est
notre thème on va dire peut-être
centrale la culture c'est un des budgets
alors le paradoxe pour présenter ces
discussions c'est que c'est une des
compétences qui n'était pas obligatoire
des conseils régionaux ça veut dire
prise de manière différente selon les
régions
une compétence dont on parle beaucoup
parce que ça concerne plein de gens des
associations des spectateurs des
pratiquants ça concerne la vie ça
concerne la vie et pour autant qu'ils
représentent peu en terme financier
quand on regarde les chiffres dans les
budgets 17 millions en bourgogne sur un
budget de 760 15 millions d'euros 10 10
millions en franche comté sur 516
millions donc on voit que c'est pas
énorme par rapport à ce que dépense la
région et pour autant on en parle
beaucoup
quelle est votre position d'abord à tous
les six on sait que les régions évolue
dans un contexte budgétaire extrêmement
tendue est ce que le budget de la
culture c'est une variable c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on peut toucher on peut
négocier si on doit avoir des priorités
on parle beaucoup de développement
économique ce sera le thème d'une autre
émission mais pourquoi pas ces vases
communicants ou est-ce que c'est
sanctuarisé ça ne bouge pas monsieur
lefebvre c'est sanctuarisé
c'est clairement sanctuarisée dans
l'état donc des budgets ce qui veut dire
et je pense que notre compétiteur si je
puis dire aura l'occasion d'en parler
puisque c'est une sanctuarisation sur
une situation qui notamment bourgogne a
été un peu malmenés on va dire sur ces
dernières années
n'empêche de toute façon la réponse est
claire et nette
ça ne sera pas une variable d'ajustement
assuré charles et pour toutes afin pour
nous et les 3% du budget effectivement
c'est quelque chose qui restera en place
simplement comment on va dépenser ses 3
% je pense que la culture la culture
je vais être caricatural mais c'est
quand même comme ça quand on voit là
quand on voit le fonctionnement je me
jette dedans le fonctionnement des frac
à l'autre des rats est directement avait
prévu d'attendre un petit peu je pense
que c'est quand même important
cette culture du petit doigt en l'air et
de la coupe de champagne et des petits
fours qui sert une caste en place j'en
veux pour exemple le frère du président
patriat président de du frac de
bourgogne pendant des années mais voilà
c'est caricatural mais c'est ça l'esprit
police.be par ailleurs c'est une
permettre il est aussi universitaire non
mais c'est pas une carrière un métier
c'est pas forcément parce que non mais
très bien mais la politique en famille
moi je quand vous allez vous allez voir
les vrais gens à nous les pour un art
populaire proche des gens alors oui on
ouvrait bien écouté que vous nous amenez
on ouvre le débat
on va peut-être pas parler si vous
voulez parler de thiviers on voulait
répondre je pense
la question c'est est ce qu'on peut
choisir à l'intérieur de la culture
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de nous
dire mais vous il ya des bonnes et des
mauvaises culture secteur on sait quoi
qu'il ya des bonnes ou des mauvaises
sculptures elles sont toutes bonnes
simplement en culture au service du vrai
du beau voilà avec un euro dépensé et
qui est un investissement n'était pas le
vrai et le bo de jacques richard des
tice et peut-être pas le vrai et le bo
de brigitte monnet très bien très bien
mais je vais leur anti que serait très
proche des gens des vrais gens je vous
garantis que la culture jean frac et
compagnie oui on va on va en discuter
comme je connais quelle est votre
définition vous de la culture qu'est-ce
que vous soyez vous souhaiteriez faire
est-ce que la région de franche-comté
par exemple qui est directement attaqué
par par le frac est ce qu'elle a mis
trop d'argent
elle subventionne à 70 % le budget frac
oui à 2h alors déjà c'est quoi aquasar
en bois la culture ça renvoie à
l'émotion à l'émancipation c'est
d'ailleurs ce que le front national
n'est même pas du tout ces démentis
a sion qui ont défoncé la capacité à
penser par soi même
donc c'est tout ce qui amène à réfléchir
à créer du lien social
sur l'ensemble des territoires alors
nous europe ecologie les verts
nous souhaitons sanctuariser les budgets
des politiques il faut dire qu'elle
explique le mot sanctuariser ça veut
dire que vous n'aurez pas baissé tout
cas on ne laissera pas qu'est ce qu'on
constate sur l'ensemble de la france
c'est qu'avec les baisses de dotations
de l'état
plus de 100 festival ont disparu
beaucoup de deux communes 95% des
communes envisagent de baisser les
dotations aux milieux culturels mais on
oublie que la culture c'est de
l'économie et que la culture ce sont des
emplois locaux non délocalisables alors
moi j'ai envie de redire la culture
c'est une richesse
au delà de la richesse de notre esprit
avec toute la variété et toute la
liberté que l'on doit laisser aux
artistes parce que lorsqu'on fait le
procès du frac c'est la liberté des
actes des artistes que l'on annonce un
seul cd budget historique je regrette
voulait répondu en plaisantant on
connaît le goût du front national pour
la culture officielle la culture
autoritaire la culture c'est ce qui nous
interpelle c'est la liberté c'est lien
social c'est le vivre ensemble c'est le
développement de la citoyenneté donc la
culture ça doit vivre ça va pas être
encadrés voit déjà d'ailleurs que sur ce
sujet-là front national c'est la
régression c'est l'enfermement dont
toute la culture elle ouvre pour qu'elle
ouvre la culture il faut qu'elles aient
des moyens donc marrons du feu dit on
sent que tu as he is les moyens dédiés à
la culture d'ailleurs en bourgogne
si ces dernières années d'une baisse sur
l'ensemble du mandat ya une hausse
considérable des crédits consacrés à la
culture
on dit aussi que certains environnements
associatif quand on dit nous
soutiendrons l'emploi associatif par
6000 emplois d'utilité sociale s'est
donné les moyens à toutes ces structures
qui font vivre partout dans les
territoires la culture de fonctionner et
puis la culture c'est aussi une
dynamique dynamique économique une
dynamique d'attractivité du territoire
quand on propose de créer un pass
culture qui permettent de
d'avoir accès à l'ensemble des sites de
la grande région bourgogne franche comté
de l'ile-de-france à l'alsace du
beaujolais à la suisse on ouvre cette
grande région sur la culture
alors mes deux frac 1 à dijon à besançon
comment vous envisagé la chose si jamais
vous êtes dans l'exécutif dans la
majorité c'est pas un problème
spécifique à la culture il ya de
nombreux domaines de compétences ou les
modes de gestion ne sont pas les mêmes
certains sont en régie d'autres sont
confiés à les associations c'est le cas
pour les frac temps qu'il faudra voir
les moyens qu'on a de les rapprocher
moi je persiste à penser au delà de la
question du mode de gestion que l'art
contemporain
c'est aussi là encore quelque chose qui
doit nous interpeller et que ça doit pas
être mis sous le boisseau que le front
national c'est ce que voulait nous ferme
et de boissons mais pas du tout sûr de
boisson lors la photo 1
mais simplement l'art contemporain faut
qu'ils parlent aux gens il parle pas aux
gens quand vous avez quand vous avez des
stocks
quand vous avez des stocks au frac de
franche comté vous avez des télévisions
fait l'avocat du diable à titre
personnel je déteste la musique
militaire
je présente à végéter sa musique d'hier
de quel droit vous allait supprimer les
subventions aux festivals de musique
monétaire ou pas vous n'aimez pas
je vous ai pas joué pas mal moins vous
êtes un parti politique pourquoi un
parti politique à un jugement esthétique
je n'ai pas sur le synthétique c'est
pratique mais vous savez quoi ça fait
penser quand même sérieusement jugement
est et des chiffres la reproduit gipa
jugement esthétique c'est fou qui se
posent la question
c'est intelligent au génie on n'a rien
on n'a rien contre l'art moderne
on n'a rien contre l'art moderne mais
faut qu'ils soient au service du beau et
proche des gens et ça c'est possible ça
ces poissons deux autres charles gallois
sur cette question du coût aux joueurs
je bats mon politique politicienne sur
ce sujet la halle herne et stephen en
esthétique on est efficace et qu'on n'a
pas à juger ce qui est beau ce qui est
pas beau effectivement ces voix là on
n'est pas là dedans
l'idée est la vraie question c'est que
si on part là dedans tout sur n'importe
quel sujet tout le monde va dire
effectivement il faut sanctuariser le
budget on va faire plus de culte dans le
nil
la vraie question c'est celle qu elle
sauvée madame c'est sur la baisse des
notations tombale très très peu c'est ça
la problématique parce qu'effectivement
le gâteau globale va diminuer sa faut
pas l'oublier à une baisse de 30 % des
dotations mais faudrait peut-être se
demander à quoi est-ce que c'est du
cette baisse de 30% des notations
vous savez que monsieur
lang qui a été élu il avait dit qu'il
négocierait le traité budgétaire au
niveau européen sauf qu'il ne l'a pas
fait c'est ce traité que j'ai test
imposé excusez moi à l'état français
des économies de 50 milliards d'euros
dont cette baisse des dotations dont
l'une l'union populaire républicaine se
propose sortir l'union européenne ça
peut vous paraître très très loin au
niveau mais on voit une conséquence
directe quand vous allez voir vos
mairies j'ai manifesté un peu de temps à
la nièvre auprès des maires qui luttent
et donc la baisse de notation c'est pas
auprès de l'état français qui doivent
aller manifester
c'est auprès de bruxelles qui est
directement responsable de ces éléments
là ce qu'il faut savoir c'est ce que
vous allez faire cela la région
bourgogne franche comté
vous allez demander de l'argent à
bruxelles pour faire plus de culture
mais déjà l'argent de bruxelles il faut
savoir c'est de l'argent français chaque
année la france donne 22 milliards union
européenne l euro soit 14 et on perd 8
milliards d'euros au passage donc c'est
de l'argent français
c'est un peu comme si je vous donne et
si vous donniez 500 euros je vous envoie
300 et en plus vous me disent que je
devais faire il est roi soit je devrais
vous dire merci
l'union européenne fondamentalement
c'est ça et ça faut jamais l'oublier
avec des marges en france justement
shirakawa s'est quand même fait pas un
débat sur l'appartenance de la france à
l'union européenne ce qui amène déjà que
le sujet est compliqué pour les
électeurs je suis pas certain que j'en
suis bien vite à gros nez et gérons
petit dont faisait par brive primer sur
les choix culturels faut quand même
expliquer d'où ça vient parce que c'est
facile après de pleurer sur les
conséquences il faut expliquer d'où ça
vient et l'union populaire républicaine
excusez moi le seul parti à le faire
alors après effectivement au niveau de
la région il ya des il ya des choses à
faire néanmoins et on a un programme
régional qui peut être appliquée il faut
pas perdre de vue qu'on peut pas
promettre des millions d'emplois on peut
pas promettre de maintenir tel ou tel
budget parce que ce n'est pas dans les
mains de la région c'est au niveau de
l'europe donc c'est bien de l'expliquer
et de comprendre d'où vient le mal géré
mon petit oui moi je voudrais revenir
quand même sur ces questions là et de la
culture la ville que je voudrais
rappeler quand même que c'est une
mission de service public déjà et que
elle est universelle c'est une source
d'émancipation importante je ne vois pas
en quoi un parti politique pourrait
juger et hugo houle buller dans le
domaine culturel
elle n'est en aucun cas une variable
d'ajustement
bien évidemment sanctuarisation je ne
sais pas si tous nos compatriotes
m entendre ce bourg mais il semblerait
il semblerait que bien sûr le budget de
la rrq de la culture ne peut être
menacée il peut même voir être augmenté
en fonction de la politique qui est
menée
nous nous souhaitons nous souhaitons que
les territoires puissent s'exprimer à
travers cette compétence de la culture
il vaut une mise en réseau je
rappellerai aussi que la culture est une
compétence partagée et que s'il la
région peut-être le pilote peut-être au
niveau territorial 1 entre tous les
acteurs autour de la culture
ça serait bien voilà donc soutenir
soutenir ce travail en réseau dans le
domaine culturel
ça nous semble un axe important mais
s'avère ou mise en réseau concrètement
concrètement sur le territoire quel
qu'il soit sur notre grande région de
demain
vous avez vous avez des acteurs qui sont
nombreux qui souffre justement d'un
manque de soutien ou de lisibilité
cette lisibilité la région doit être là
pour justement les les aider ça veut
dire quoi concrètement un réseau quand
vous avez eu par exemple une compagnie
théâtre qui va appeler à l'aide
à travers une subvention pour 2,2
spectacle pourquoi ces deux spectacles
pour deux représentations seulement
pourquoi justement avec la mise en
réseau cette représentation ne serait
pas développé au niveau régional c'est
une intelligence ont une intelligence
des dépense des deniers publics
vous avez 7 cette manifestation qui va
se développer à l'échelle régionale au
lieu d'avoir deux représentations et
blanc avec 15 et vous satisfait et qui
nous satisfaisait des citoyens voilà
j'en fais du club où il était parti sur
la question du budget sécurisé on évite
de parler on a glissé sur le seul à la
définition d'une politique culturelle
c'est quoi une politique culturelle dans
une politique de territoire
moi j'allais dire on peut on peut le
résumer en trois points sur les
finitions très flou de la loi notre
d'ailleurs le terme
le terme culturelle ne peut être
associée comme aux politiques parce que
si c'est au moment où l'intervention
en l'occurrence l'intervention publique
se voir c'est l'épanouissement des
individus c'est l'apaisement d'une
société parce que la culture permet une
relation sociale ça c'est souvent en
famille ça se partage
il ya une notion de partage dans dans
l'expérience culturelle et puis elle
rayonnement d'une région bon alors pour
en revenir à au débat qui a été lancée
sur quelle est la place du politique par
rapport à l'action culturelle
moi j'utilise toujours la même phrase je
dis orienté n'est pas choisir mais
orienté et si on s'oriente sur la
question du frac la question pour moi
comme pour mes amis n'est pas de faire
des choix esthétiques mais aussi un jeu
chez un parallèle savait au moment où
les politiques ont vraiment fait des
choix acheter des oeuvres pour leurs
musées c'était à la fin du 19e siècle
ils ont fait quoi ils sont passés à côté
des impressionnistes et on veut pas dire
que les impressionnistes soit une
émotion qui ne soit pas positive et ils
ont choisi les peintres pompiers que
plus personne ne regarde aujourd'hui
boudreau ou de taille donc que je veux
dire par là c'est que sur l'esthétique
c'est pas un supporter pour moi ça n'est
pas un sujet par contre orienté c'est à
dire avoir une politique claire et
lisible et notamment par rapport au frac
orale et ça pose trois vraies questions
d'abord celle du frac en bourgogne qui
soit un frac bourguignon beaucoup plus
qu'un frac dijonnais parce que la
réalité quand on regarde il suffit
d'aller aujourd'hui sur le site du frac
bourgogne sur toutes les propositions du
frac bourgogne il n'y en a qu'une à
l'extérieur dans l'yonne
ensuite c'est celle de l'itinérance de
la réalité moi je parle de proximité
effectivement l'art contemporain n'est
pas forcément
d'abord c'est pas forcément toujours
difficile je vous invite à venir en ce
moment au musée dole et l'exposition
pourtant qu'il parte pas si simple et
qui a un beau succès mais c'est celle
effectivement de donner des clés
en fait la vraie question des frac c'est
celle de leur politique bacio culture
est des frac parlant en particulier et
de la culture
j'allais dire parce que quel est
l'argument ayant demandé à vis du frag
mais il ya bien d'autres on a la vraie
question des cr elle descend très jeunes
ou du livre siel 2
bien sûr il y en a deux il y en a même
trois avec l'accolade en franche comté
qui ont pour le coup un vrai rôle
économique ont parlé du rôle économique
l'accompagnement de l'économie du livre
on a deux orchestres leur caisse victor
hugo alors qu'est-ce dijon bourgogne
voilà on a des questions qui se posent
effectivement moi je voulais dit tout à
l'heure un nous on respecte l'identité
des deux territoires nord ça veut dire
concrètement si vous êtes dans la
majorité au mois de janvier
vous faites comment avec deux frappes
deux orchestres trois centres régionaux
du livre mais je alors je reprends le le
propos 1 / d'abord on oriente c'est à
dire qu'on donne une visibilité très
clair à une politique culturelle que
l'on va le terme de partager c'est une
oeuvre s'est pas uniquement partager
avec les collectivités c'est partager
aussi avec les acteurs et sur nos
propositions sur nos lignes on demandera
aux institutions culturelles qui relève
de la région de la tutelle de la région
de s'inscrire dans des orientations mais
non pas de choisir est allé de
travailler à la politique de coopération
mutualisation vous savez je suis celui
qui a créé je suis celui qui a créé
scène du jura je peux vous dire qu'en
termes de mutualisation et coopération
j'ai un peu d'expérience dans le domaine
on va donner la parole à à jérôme durain
sur chaque région et après jacques
richard getty sur la question
d'organisation de la filière culturelle
crois qu'il faut qu'on parle de filières
actuelles
il ya une question de moyens questions
d'organisation de question de dynamique
les moyens j'ai dit on les sent que tu
as he is et on met des emplois
associatifs 6000 à disposition des
associations ça c'est la base après les
acteurs culturels nous nous devons de
quoi il nous demande de la visibilité
ils veulent savoir sur quel crédit
peuvent compter avec peut-être des
projets de conventions pluriannuelles
pour sécuriser les financements il nous
demande du dialogue pour savoir sur quoi
ils peuvent compter comment on peut les
aider
et je crois que si la région nouvelle
s'il nouvel exécutif s'engage dans ces
deux voies on peut sécuriser une filière
culturelle qui va travailler sur la
mutualisation ça vient le dit sûr de la
mise en réseau sur du maillage
territorial
on peut imaginer des dynamiques
autour de grands événements nous nous
proposons une fête régionale de la
culture
on peut imaginer plus localement de
favoriser les rapprochements entre les
structures pour qu'elle puisse céder les
unes les autres
avoir des programmations partager je
crois que c'est vraiment cette dynamique
là qu'il faut envisager autour d'une
volonté de faire profiter la culture à
tous
ça va des cafés culture locaux à auxerre
une autre idée aux scènes nationales se
souvient d'autres puisque la région
franche-comté des partenaires là il faut
avoir une vision dynamique de la culture
en soutenant les acteurs qui ont besoin
de visibilité
jusqu'à maintenant c'était des drags qui
faisaient ça donc il faut pallier les
manquements de l'état régional des
affaires culturelles
on parle beaucoup dans la chronique les
élus politiques les élus régionaux
prennent leurs responsabilités vis-à-vis
d une filière qui est indispensable à la
vie de la grande région
on va remarquer d'ailleurs quand on
parlait de direction des affaires
culturelles que le budget de la culture
dans les régions à monter ces dernières
années pendant que le budget national de
la culture besset et que c'est un peu un
jeu de vases communicants et la culture
la culture c'est 2 % en franche-comté et
c'est un petit peu plus de deux mandats
il est tout à la fois que charles était
votre l'action rebondit sur ce que vous
dites effectivement tout le monde autour
de la table et
ok pour sanctuariser c'est budget autour
d'eux un petit 3 % d'accord là dessus
voilà j'aimerais revenir sur tout à
l'heure j'étais largement caricature et
la culture
non non c'est largement facile
simplement nous on revient à 2 revient
c'est ce que j'ai dit on n'a rien contre
l'art contemporain ça c'est pas un
problème simplement quand on voit des
compacteurs juste pour les
téléspectateurs frac parce qu on utilise
ce mot là c'est des fonds qui ont été
créés dans les années 80 pour développer
l'art contemporain dans les régions il
accepte il a coûté par son bâtiment en
franche-comté 9 millions c'est un
million sept ses amis ont 7 par an de
frais de fonctionnement
c'est trois fois moins cher en bourgogne
cfm 4000 personnes rendez compte 24
personnes qu'ils visitent
il n'y a pas la moitié des gens qui
payent s'ils voulaient bien tout cet
argent elle pourrait être utilisée pour
faire quelque chose que les journaux
gratuits pour tout à l'heure il joue
court bea est excité tout à l'heure donc
le musée gustave courbet à ornans par
exemple pour vous c'est un régional donc
il faut bien sûr l'accompagné il ya
combien de visiteurs au musée courbet
chacun j'en sais rien moi je veux dit 24
à 24 milles au frac les jeux je prends
la cathédrale saint-jean c'est 120 mails
mais et corrigé 66000 voilà d'accord il
ya quand même un problème quand je vois
c'est que je ne sais pas non plus mais
sa passion de la régionale est interdite
ce dédale comme vous dites aux gens 9
millions plus 1 million c'est tous les
ans je vous parle même pas du du petit
camion satellite à 75000 euros pour 20
mètres cubes jeudi contre un petit
camion qui circuleront par les faire
circuler les oeuvres un petit camion qui
circulent on l'a réaménagé pour 75
millions oui mais c'était intéressant
que ces petits caïds justement dans nos
métiers mais c'est donc dans des dents
comme vous quand vous parlez de ça des
gens qui souffrent qui sont dans la
difficulté
vous leur parlez de
de 75000 euros c'est l'argent ça se
prêterait à sourire oui et 75000 euros
pour 20 mètres cubes
voilà alors on a un déficit de temps de
parole sur les candidates logique je
crois que quand même je tiens à rappeler
que la culture n'est pas une variable
d'ajustement au niveau budgétaire mais
non n'est pas non plus à mettre en porte
à faux par rapport à la misère des gens
la culture est un lien social primordial
donc je ne peux pas laisser dire ce qui
vient d'être dit entre autres les frac
bien et bien évidemment que nous nous
souhaitons plus de visibilité sur leur
fonctionnement
la question se pose d'un frac
bourguignons mais pourquoi chaque frack
ne garderait pas son identité si si la
politique je je tiens quand même à
rappeler que certains propos sont plus
qu'inquiétants concernant les frac deux
doigts part de vos amis monsieur mettons
sur la place publique les oeuvres et
puis mettez non aux enchères ou brûlons
les commet peu le peut-on laisser se
dire ça je sais ce qu'il dit cher
monsieur que j'ai dit ça a été dit ça
veut dire que vous sous-estimez
complètement l'importance de la culture
dans notre pays est donc levé sur
notoriété rite war voilà vous fera sans
autre en bourgogne où son style parce
qu'ils aiment c'est miller et le millas
royaume mais rendons ses oeuvres
accessibles de nous nous demanderons à
ce que ces fonds soient le plus connu
possible disponible pour la population
puisque c'est leur but ce je ne pense
pas que la conservation ne sont pas des
musées 1 ce sont des fonds ils doivent
ils doivent être mis à disposition va
dire delà de la population sur les
équilibres du fonctionnement et
l'investissement de 2 cd greuze frac et
dans la région doit être attentive
bien sûr par rapport au niveau
budgétaire puis c'est tout
alors s'il ya bien une compétence qui
est une compétence régionale ce sont
bien des vracs et effectivement c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure le frag
c'est déjà un fond et ce n'est pas amusé
néanmoins il y a eu une volonté
politique et notamment de la vice
présidente en charge de la culture vite
présidente écologiste de franche comté
de justement porté auprès du public et
du grand public des oeuvres qu'ils
resteraient inconnue deux si on n'avait
pas fait le bus satellite si on ne
faisait pas des interventions en milieu
scolaire ce ne faisait pas des ateliers
au sein du frac lui même si on n'allait
pas dans les prisons à la rencontre de
personnes qui sont très éloignées de d
globalement je dirais des oeuvres
culturelles qui sont dans dans ces
structures
mersen il est de l'intérêt du concept et
des douleurs comme monsieur richard des
titres dits 70000 euros pour 75 mille
pour 20 mètres comme vous dites quoi
ça fait cher du mètre cube vous vous dit
il c'est nécessaire moi je dis c'est
nécessaire parce que justement on va
partout avec ce bus satellite
on y règle ans l'intégralité du
territoire quand tout à l'heure je
disais qu'est bientôt la population l
année essentiellement je vous en prie la
population est essentiellement dans les
villages dans l'île rousse en bourgogne
et franche comté et bien notre devoir en
tant que politique c'est d'amener la
culture au plus près pour la cohésion
sociale et notamment en période de
difficultés économiques
moi je pense que plus que jamais on doit
maintenir à la hauteur de 3 % c'est ce
que nous nous portons 3 % des budgets du
futur budget régional pour la culture en
tenant les deux bouts c'est à dire d'un
côté les grandes structures régionales
voire à dimension nationale
mais de l'autre côté est vraiment la
culture en direction du milieu
sur ce qu'on voulait comme suit et vous
allez tous vous exprimer dessus bien sûr
sur cette émission on n'a pas d'exemple
du frac notre s'offre un nombre de
points budgétaire il ya des choix je le
disais en commençant ce chapitre
différent selon les régions sur les
choix culturels ya des régions qui ont
décidé de se concentrer on va dire sur
une culture locale interne à la région
qui va des lycées aux compagnies locales
et puis il ya des choix parfois beaucoup
plus extérieur qui sont par exemple de
financer des spectacles qui vont sortir
de la région de financer des films par
exemple qui vont se tourner dans une
région
quelle est votre position et là c'est
vraiment important dans la campagne qui
commence aux uns et aux autres là dessus
est-ce que quel est pour vous le choix
qui doit être fait les deux c'est à dire
interne et du rayonnement de la région
vers l'extérieur où les contraintes
budgétaires les choix font qu' il faut
se concentrer sur l'intérieur en
commençant par jérôme durain voulu y
répondre
j'ai réuni d'aborder quelque chose à moi
je vous réponds d'aller vers un point
qui est évoqué churchill quand on lui
disait qu'il fallait tailler dans les
crédits culturels pour financer l'effort
de guerre a répondu mais à quoi cela
sert-il que nous nous mettions donc il
n'y a pas d'opposition entre les budgets
et je trouve que l'argument les 75 euros
ici c'est trop faut pas sortir les
chiffres de leur contexte parce que ça
n'a pas de sens donc tout ça pour dire
que la sanctuary zèle général de gaulle
et churchill
vous avez placé le débat est basée la
question quand même de la
sanctuarisation qui paraît clair à tout
le monde moi j'attire l'attention sur le
fait qu'un syndrome de municipalités
droite élus en 2014 ont commencé à taper
dans les crédits culture comme je disais
à châlons - 25 %
donc il faut il faut aussi rétablir les
choses parce qu'avant l'élection du des
choses après il ya eu des baisses de
subventions que les festivals par la
région aussi sa hausse malaisie
valentino secondes en moyenne
c'est également répartis sur tout le
territoire on verra ça de près deuxième
sujet la position il n'y a pas
d'opposition entre l'intérieur et
l'extérieur pour le pense qu'on peut
faire de la médiation culturelle
nous proposons nous proposons par
exemple la généralisation de la carte
avantages jeunes qui existent en franche
comté à tout le territoire bourguignon
franc comtois mais on propose aussi de
poursuivre l'aide aux tournages à la
production et la diffusion
cinématographique sur la grande région
il me semblerait la franche-comté
l'avait fait
était tout à fait mais du coup c'est les
campagnes c'est l'occasion aussi de
définir des objectifs de s'interroger
donc la réponse c'est celle là intérieur
extérieur intérieur extérieur
j'ai pas terminé je repars dangereux sur
l'identité j'ai eu tout à l'heure le
sentiment quand même qu'on avait une
vision parfois un petit peu étriqué un
petit peu moisie de ce que va être les
territoires il faut rester chez soi il
faut pas bouger la grande région ces
dynamiques en avoir envie il faut voir
il faut se projeter
donc nous on est sur l'idée que c'est à
la fois du développement on en parlera
sur tourisme du développement pour les
bons essayé et aisée c'est à faire du
tennis et de l'attractivité donc il faut
faire les deux tout le monde va
s'exprimer alors sur sun pour le coup
nous on note deux axes troie en
l'occurrence mais deux axes nous
intéresse là tout de suite dans la
discussion
c'est que nous nous défendre et une
politique de proximité et d'irrigation
des territoires donc en direction des
habitants de la bourgogne et la
franche-comté et l'autre ces deux
favoriser l'ambiance culturelle et on
peut d'en favoriser l'ambiance
culturelle
voir aussi toute la question du
rayonnement à l'extérieur
nous on pense clairement qu'en bourgogne
franche comté un certain nombre
d'événements ou un rayonnement qui
touche l'ensemble du pays
vraiment l'ensemble de la france et un
certain autres d'autres événements donc
je pense notamment aux eurockéennes et à
chalon dans la rue mais d'autres
événements ont un rayonnement on va dire
qu'il dépasse nos frontières et d'autres
événements des rayonnements un
rayonnement va dire français pense à ce
qui peut se passer notamment corps que
notamment dans le domaine des de la
musique classique
bref on pourrait on pourrait y revenir
moi je pense que les deux vont ensemble
et puisque vous parliez du cinéma c'est
assez intéressant parce que je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un vrai moyen de
rayonnement sauf que la bourgogne mais à
peu près 800 mille euros si mes
souvenirs sont bons sur les docks dans
le domaine du cinéma
la franche-comté 0 alors on fait quoi
huit cent mille divisé par deux non mais
la question c'est 800 mille divisé par
deux pour l'an prochain c'est à dire
c'est à dire qu'on déshabille un peu la
bourgogne pour habiller un petit peu la
franche comté
ça sera c'est une vraie question
d'accord et
comme moi je pense qu'effectivement le
cinéma auquel on est très attaché
j'allais dire que comme 12 mois j'y suis
d'autant plus attachée que pendant très
longtemps le centre franc comtois du
cinéma était à dole et qu'il était le
bureau d'accueil et qu'il a été passée
par pertes et profits par la région de
franche-comté doit doit être soutenue
aujourd'hui
bref là une politique culturelle qui
marche sur les deux sur ses deux jambes
c'est vers les bourgs les bourguignons
et les franc comtois est donnée cette
ambiance régional à l'extérieur
messieurs richard d'eads si à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur
c'est très simple on va décliner la
préférence nationale en préférence
régionale
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire effectivement développé ce qui
marche chez nous 1 on a des acteurs de
terrain nous avons des compagnies et les
compagnies de cirque qui sont qui sont
régionales et brillante
nous avons peu développé le cinéma je
pense que ce serait très important parce
que les le cinéma c'est l'image à
l'extérieur mais avec du cinéma chez
nous et des productions locales
en attendant précisément donc des films
qui seront diffusés sur le réseau
national
bien sûr des films nationaux mais tourné
chez nous le rayonnement l'accès c'est
le principe en général la subvention par
les régions sac pas tout à fait mais
j'ai jamais dis qu'on a quand même je
suis je suis même plutôt court voilà je
suis pour ça c'est ça c'est de la
préférence régionale
cette préférence très géniale elle se
décline aussi sur les métiers d'art 1
pouces quel métier d'earth à développer
on a on a aussi en terme en termes de
culture dont on ne parle pas beaucoup
fumé le tue le tourisme et la culture
c'est sur nos deux territoires bourgogne
et franche comté c'est sans une sans une
appellation d'origine contrôlée
ça aussi c'est du local 1 voilà en
termes aussi on peut revenir aussi en
terme de
de financement public quand il ya des
appels d'offres mettre une préférence
vous mettre une préférence via les
critères environnementaux et sociaux
pour des entreprises locales
que ce soit en termes de production vos
autres oui si on va faire encore tourner
la parole rapidement monsieur gallois
alors sûrement intérieur extérieur sur
la culture a une vision un peu plus
large si vous voulez ce que pour nous la
culture ça a été dit d'ailleurs
auparavant c'est un moyen d'ouverture
sur le monde
donc on veut des bleus vais évidemment
au niveau local on veut d'ailleurs nous
mettre le paquet sur tout ce qui est
culture historique on a un patrimoine
historique qui est quand même assez
phénoménal que seront bons gagnent en
franche comté on peut penser château de
bazoches gew non la citadelle de
besançon etc
lou l'idée essayez quelque part aussi l
politique des lycées l'éducation c'était
une priorité que on se réapproprie notre
patrimoine local parce que il ya aucun
pays même aucune région a fortiori qui
se relève et qui va de l'avant si elle
n'est pas un peu fier de ses racines et
c'est également une ouverture sur le
monde
on aimerait que les médias locaux
puissent par exemple diffusé on le voit
j'aime on voit que des films américains
grosso modo on aimerait on aimerait voir
par exemple des films russes et des très
bons films coréens des films brésiliens
je vois pourquoi en fait on serait sur
une culture juste une culture américaine
on pourrait beaucoup plus s'ouvrir sur
le monde et les harmonisations c'est
difficilement compétences des régions la
diffusion si on peut on peut pousser pas
forcément nationale il ya des chaînes
justement lequel on peut pousser des
chaînes locales à le faire c'est l'idée
de la région et c'est cette articulation
le patrimoine français et l'ouverture
sur le monde
c'est petit mais c'est un petit dans wii
pour qu'on parle d'eux un petit peu en
local ou ouverts j'ai un bon j'ai dit
tout à l'heure à la culture elle est
universelle pour nous avant tout elle
n'est pas simplement une offre non plus
il faut que les citoyens se
réapproprient la culture et qui ce
qu'ils en soient acteurs donc
obligatoirement chaque territoire se
doit d'être porteurs de projets le
rayonnement régional va de pair notre
région et han
situé au carrefour de haut niveau
national voire même européen donc nous
soutiendrons les grands poche projet
mais nous soutiendrons bien évidemment
tous projets locaux avec une identité
territoriale qui coule de source
brigitte monnet encore un mot sur cette
histoire de culture sur ce débat de
culture passe au tourisme d'accord je
dis qu'il faut surtout pas se
recroqueviller sur soi-même la culture
c'est d'ouverture donc et bien et on le
voit au travers des festivals quand on
voit du festival du film d'asie et à
bien d'autres août à bezouce ou
d'amérique latine à lons le saunier on
voit que ça bouillonne partout et que
cette ouverture elle est bien présente
alors je voulais faire un apartheid est
quand même on dit faut faire vivre au
niveau des territoires
moi je voulais souvenir que certains
territoires aujourd'hui sont en
difficulté quand on voit par exemple que
la fraternelle est en grande difficulté
vous avez consacré à une émission hier
soir cette association qui porte la
mémoire de la culture ouvrière sur le
haut jura
faute de financement et avec des baisses
de financement d'une municipalité de
droite se voit aujourd'hui obligé est
bien de faire appel à la générosité
publique pour pouvoir continuer à vivre
mon la région a apporté 1 et continue à
importer de la fraternelle mais là c'est
un exemple des dégâts qu'il y des
baisses de dotations de subventions de
la part des collectivités locales pour
l'emploi on va vous parler maintenant du
tourisme
si vous le voulez bien pour le tourisme
en quelques chiffres en bourgogne c'est
11 millions d'euros pour le tourisme et
le thermalisme en franche comté c'est
presque 7 millions c'est à dire à peu
près 1,3 4% du budget s'est tout de même
3 milliards d'euros qui sont dépensés
pour le tourisme dans notre grande
région et ses quarante mille emplois on
va commencer avec vous monsieur richard
des types quelle place donneriez-vous au
tourisme dans si vous jamais vous étiez
à la tête de cette nouvelle
une grande région bourgogne franche
comté en précisant d'ailleurs ont changé
un peu de registre parce que
budgétairement c'est plutôt classé dans
le développement économique on en parle
mais on voit l'enjeu c'est important
effectivement le tourisme c'est le
développement économique ou la vie 10 à
15 tonnes rappelé moins 15 milliards 3
voilà j'étais optimiste roy miller
effectivement le tout le tourisme c'est
l'identité notre de nos deux belles
régions la bourgogne et la franche comté
avec avec comme je disais tout à l'heure
sans sens une appellation d'origine
contrôlée
c'est pas rien c'est pas rien un titre
aig clôturait quatre aujourd'hui
tout tout tout alla des interconnexions
parce que bien évidemment l'attractivité
d'une région c'est aussi ce qu'on peut
et ce qu'on peut y déguster un ça c'est
très important nous avons nous avons la
chance d'avoir d'avoir et la vigne parce
que je reviens là aussi ça fait partie
du tourisme ça c'est pas seulement
c'est pas seulement du poids économique
c'est aussi du tourisme des châteaux
et une station de ski à métabief donc
c'est très très informé c'est différent
aussi
pour aller un peu voire pas ce qu'on va
dire que passons sur le préambule tout
le monde est d'accord sur l'idée c'est
bruce bourse de l'argent tout va bien
tout à perdre un petit de façon quand
même un petit peu plus serré est ce
qu'on vend une seule grande région
puisqu'on va être une même structure
et s'il faut garder les structures
différencier qu'étaient les conseils
régionaux du tourisme qui travaillaient
quand même sur sur leur propre des
comités partenaires cicatrice sur sur
leur propre région c'est ça qu'il faut
savoir tu as fait alors bon là ils sont
si nous énumérer les sens une
appellation d'origine
on est bien d'accord sur ça bien
évidemment il va falloir faire aussi des
économies sur les structures là aussi on
viendra un principe de bon sens on ne
pourra pas fait avoir des doublons
partout un bien évidemment et on
s'attachera à 1 euro investi et un euro
dans un entretien dans une structure
qu'est ce qu'elle rapporte et comment
elle fonctionne bien évidemment on
arrivera à des ajustements avec des
structures regroupées et serré parce
qu'effectivement il ya une cohésion
je pense que la cohésion la cohésion la
la la la plus importante de nos deux
régions c'est la cohésion touristique
alors on va commencer par part vous
justement pour ce tour de table le
tourisme vous le voyez comment dans
votre programme nous le voyons l'origine
envoyons regrouper nous voyons regroupés
à l'échelle de la nouvelle région
nous nous proposons un tourisme social
solidaire donc à l'échelle de la région
et ce pour soutenir toutes les actions
qui seraient mises en oeuvre
je ne crois pas que les professionnels
du tourisme ont attendu que la grande
région se fasse
d'ailleurs l'union nationale des
associations de tourisme est en train de
fusionner avant même l'arrêt
arrivé à les gens ont préparé cette
année c'est au minimum grand test dans
certains domaines donc nous n'allons pas
soutenir une politique territoriale on
ancien bourgogne enseigne ancienne femme
franche comté nous nous souhaitons que
le touriste qui est un acteur économique
on est tous d'accord pour le dire
soit soutenue mais et d'autres d'autres
orientations
voilà donc notre orientation c'est à
dire que nous souhaitons que soit mis
nous gardons nous allons prenez le
tourisme d'itinérance nous nous allons
mettre en valeur le tourisme pédestre le
tourisme à travers les stations de ski
était un tourisme et qu'est ce qu'on
doit le plus dire qu'on doit comprendre
que c'est une critique contre ce qu'elle
fait jusqu'à maintenant
non non et encore non mais non on est
aussi dans la perspective d'une élection
proposer d'autres orientations dans les
rangs je crois que simplement les
acteurs doivent tous est convié autour
de la table pour ce sujet là je le
rappelle le tourisme et d'une compétence
aussi partagé et et qu' il faut un peu
plus de cohérence sur nos territoires
d'autant plus que notre territoire ça
grandit à travers la grande région
il faut plus de cohérence et nous nous
souhaitons que les citoyens et tous les
acteurs et les professionnels du
tourisme soit partie prenante du projet
encore une fois la région ne doit pas
simplement être là en tant que
collectivité qui va faire une offre qui
va mettre un budget à disposition sans
logique sans logique ni territoriale
je crois que sur le tourisme qu'on ne
peut pas simplement être dans l'ia caf
aux cons on va s'appuyer sur nos
productions traditionnelles il faut le
faire cette évidence est une de nos
richesses il faut une stratégie la
bourgogne franche comté sur la carte
d'appel de la planète c'est qu'un numéro
de téléphone
comment on existe comment se montre
comment on va chercher du monde et nous
on a une stratégie qui est de créer une
marque bourgogne franche comté pour
exister pour alerter les touristes pour
attirer du monde âgée qui avait déjà été
qui avait déjà développé collet xive
ardt un vice présidente sortante à la
région bourgogne
elle est allée chercher des touristes à
hong kong pour les années ici c'est les
gens qui consomment
ici nos produits nos produits de luxe
qui consomment notre vin qui consomment
notre gastronomie qui font des nuitées
dans le territoire mais ça ne s'oppose
pas d'autres formes de tourisme et aussi
du tourisme social
ça a été dit précédemment et aussi du
tourisme familial cd projet de center
parcs donc il faut avoir une stratégie
une stratégie qui soit on peut en parler
mais on peut en parler sereinement une
stratégie un tour de table
parce que je crois qu on a quelques
atouts qui sont très importants c'est le
no tourisme c'est nos grands sites et on
propose d'ailleurs d'avoir un label qui
permet d'aller sur tous les grands sites
unesco
les six et puis le tourisme et
d'itinérance arrive à ses côtés de huit
sites unesco sur 41 en france quand on
rajoute quand même les sites naturels
comme les grands lacs
et puis également le 8 le deuxième site
qui m'échappe m'en fait la belle en tout
cas un label pour l'ensemble et qu'il y
avait aussi trois parcs régionaux
naturel donc le haut jura le ballon des
bouges et et le mauvais non membres
voilà donc la belle et la bête
je vais montrer en train la belle pour
tous à un itinéraire qui rallie les
sites unesco
et puis un tourisme et d'itinérance qui
utilisent tous les sites de votre liste
les réserves naturelles qui sont
nombreuses par exemple en franche comté
et est également tout le monde soit
d'accord sur les outils comme sur les
outils sur les atouts du jeu
cet hiver je me fais une station de ski
y'a pas que métallier il ya aussi des
rousses et a aussi la planche des belles
filles et c'est terminé
vous allez en parler en général vous
voulez attaquer sur certaines séries
alors moi je suis vous donner les trois
critères que nous écologistes nous
portons pour un tourisme durable
premièrement c'est un tourisme qui est
supportable sur le plan écologique est
bien évidemment un tourisme supportable
ça ne va veut dire que nous n'irions pas
sur les deux center parcs prévue aux
rousses est et au delà
juste une toute petite parenthèse comme
on n'a pas été très précis tout à
l'heure sur le frac
là il faut savoir 200 interfax un haut
rousset en saône-et-loire oui et un
autre à poligny dans le jura
l'opérateur est un opérateur privé lycée
pierre et vacances qui veut faire tous
fait donc débat gallo piscine avec deux
au minimum 30 degrés toute l'année et
ses thérapies et avec des problèmes
notamment d'approvisionnement et de
rejet en haut de gamme d'appareils tout
petit exemple que par exemple le le
conseil régional de bourgogne lors d'une
même séance à voter 60 millions d'euros
en direction du center parcs de recettes
et à voter dans la même séance 4
millions d'euros pour le développement
du tourisme durable
donc c'est pas possible de continuer
comme ça ensuite on voit bien la
différence
ensuite c'est un tourisme viable sur le
plan économique
donc pour qu'il soit viable aussi sur le
plan économique sa demande
la montée en compétence des taux des
professionnels du tourisme ce que font
les conseils les comités régionaux du
tourisme et il faut qu'ils soient
équitables et qui tape sur le plan
social faut quand même pas oublier que
50 % des ouvriers ne partent pas en
vacances ça veut dire que leurs enfants
non plus ne partent pas en vacances
et lorsque nous portons nous fortement
le développement
la reprise du village de vacances de
lamoura et bien c'est aussi pour
permettre au tourisme social et familial
de continuer à exister sur notre
territoire de tradition ouvrière quand
même né l'oublions pas charles-henri
gallois sur ce sujet en précisant qu'il
nous reste une minute trente mais qu'on
continuera après que l'âge de midi la
discussion là dessus je vous rassure je
suivrai fait les gros yeux mais on
continue après comme du centaure pas je
suis rentré en jeu sujet luperce robot
au niveau national de rétablir la
démocratie donc évidemment qu'on veut le
faire également sur le plan local
ça se traduit comme ça se traduit par
des référendums pour tous les sujets qui
impacte effectivement l'environnement et
l'écologie est également tous les sujets
où les contribuables doivent mettre la
main à la poche pour des montants assez
important donc lui bears propose de
faire des référendums ces sujets là pas
des référendums sorti de nulle part
parce qu'ils auraient des débats
contradictoires avec des gens pour des
gens contre auparavant et ce sera aux
citoyens de trancher sur ces sujets là
ça me paraît être la méthode la plus
démocratique de le faire et j'ose
espérer que ce sera mis en place
incessamment sous peu
monsieur le faire en 30 secondes
allez à huy en 30 secondes ça allait
bien non mais certains considèrent bien
parce que vous surveillez l'horloge donc
je ne vous donne pas la parole
on va bien sûr continuer ce débat sur le
tourisme juste après les informations de
midi la suite sur le tourisme alors on a
amorcé center parcs mais faudra que vous
nous donniez votre conception aussi
général voilà de l'avenir et puis il y
aura des conclusions dans un ordre qu'on
a tiré au sort avant l'émission
voilà six minutes la formation de la
mi-journée qu'on retrouve en bourgogne
et en franche comté et nous on se
retrouve juste après pour la deuxième
partie de ce débat a tout de suite